they're ready when you are Persephone
they are in the briefing room yes ma'am
Hollywood fortune and hardtack are oh I
know who I asked for Friday look here
see these three they call themselves the
franchise for good - no none of this is
going through their heads hell yeah
franchise force is back in action
I gave us a nickname you can't just give
yourself a nickname this is Hollywood
ostentatious showboat Oh
reality TV staff and former adult film
actor when I need over-the-top and
unnecessary spectacle then Hollywood is
my top pick just walked into the danger
zone now Sky Pirates are notorious for
being selfish untrustworthy backstabbing
thieves but I'm willing to overlook
certain peccadilloes if I still get
results and fortune with those pistols
of hers and attitude to spare gets me
results plus she makes good use of a
drone glory
you ready to dance when you are
the captain approved and yes they'll
hardtack everybody loves him so you want
me to [ __ ] it up don't don't you he's
big he's loud and nobody enjoys
annihilating Legion more than he does I
almost worry about him almost
yes
these agents require specific handling
and apparently I must account for an
array of cost intensive preferences but
I recruited every one of them for
because I know the best weapon we have
is unpredictability hold on to your body
and my ancient specialize in it
come get some I love to get Legion hats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]